hey I'm going guys now as I told you
guys in the previous episode we went to
Hawaii to go see Bart and Joe Joe Joe G
oh [ __ ] Bart and geo get made obviously
more than just a marriage itself it was
just to spend time with our friends and
also finally take a quick break and even
a bigger reason for me to go on this
trip was actually to meet Bart and Geo's
parents now you guys haven't heard a lot
about Bart's mom now you can go and
check on Bart's channel later on to see
how crazy this woman is but it's not
even the tip of the iceberg look how
[ __ ] peaceful she is at first she's
just peaceful [ __ ] beet truck does
she make that up I think so I hope she
didn't ever observe what she's counting
on i watch watch nah she's drunk whoa
not just on shrooms I was like a Dalek
as a [ __ ] now did you go to
[ __ ] Coachella just start even in the
most uncomfortable situations she would
smile and I swear to god you just have
to do it because she's doing it and of
course I got to converse a little bit
with Gio's family as well now you have
seen Gio's dead and mom on her channel
before but the person that I am the most
interested in is her father now when you
look at Gio's dad you might be a little
bit intimidated because of the fact that
he has a very stern and stoic face now
notice that I don't have any footage of
this man because he scares the [ __ ] out
of me don't get it twisted the man has a
heart of gold he is a very very very
kind and wonderful man it's just that my
main mission was to make him you know
what the funny thing is later on during
that night but we went to go eat dinner
I actually made Gio's dad laugh but he
was so abrupt with the way he gave he
laughed out loud of the joke that he
realized he was laughing so he just took
it back real quick hahaha yes oh so fun
a mother of a [ __ ] that cut me huh ha
ha but you guys know I've talked a lot
about Bart and how much I love the dude
it let's talk about geo a little bit for
a second she has someone who I consider
family and also my sister but the way
that we bicker you guys always see on
the channel and you're like no
librelucha Danny no but I love the woman
to death but despite her monstrous hands
she has a very kind heart and a very
gentle touch there was a funny little
moment on the beach world asking her to
be sexy and [ __ ] you guys ever noticed
that background music can change the
mood of anything that you shoot say SIBO
dip a deer Templeton croissants tank
chocolates Lila French little tutu left
friend and yes you [ __ ] perverts I
got a clip for you Gio take it away
now of course to top off the night we
decide to go eat dinner and what we
decided to go was this place called GU
Kaku now GU Kaku is actually Japanese
barbecue joint and there are locations
in LA now I know you guys saw a video
what I did it on Korean barbecue but
Japanese barbecue is a bit of a
different situation here keep the fire
going is great footage flavours are
different the cuts of meat are different
as well and especially the side dishes
personally I love you Kaku now I
understand that for a lot of you out
there you don't understand the concept
of ordering food and then you cook it at
your table seems like you're doing the
work for the people but it's a very
unique community experience we had beef
tongue we had short ribs we had other
types of fatty pieces of meat and one of
my favorite things that I order at guca
who of course is the bacon-wrapped enoki
mushrooms I love the texture of enoki
mushrooms and then that smoky fatty
bacon around it after you grill it is
amazing now a beginner tip for you guys
when you go to this restaurant make sure
that you order a side of garlic butter
and when you dip that into a grilled
piece of meat trust me your dick will be
seven times bigger and if you don't have
a penis your vagina will be high and if
you're in the Hawaii location and you
want to top it off with a delicious
cocktail I got the lilikoi leaking
something something was bombers [ __ ] it
was salty from the leaking a little bit
of a kick from that spice as well and
then it was tempered off with the
sweetness of the leaking slush and the
alcohol amazing one of the better things
that I like about gu Kaku in their
Japanese grills compared to Korean
barbecues is that the vent and the fan
is actually underneath the grill and it
sucks it downwards rather than upwards
so when you leave from the restaurant
your clothes don't smell like ash and
delicious meat yes my friends that's
life eat drink get fat and be happy but
be healthy none of that makes sense I'll
see you next episode
Oh
you